e aí galera que se vai tornando com você
e eu estou está bem bom acabei de chegar
do show que eu fiz em campina grande e
joão pessoa na paraíba foi massa de mais
uma imagem até 23 mil já o da tyco e
agora dia 28 de março sábado e voltar em
fortaleza ceará meu deus estou muito
feliz que eu estou voltando em fortaleza
já foi uma vez à afp um dos primeiros
shows sempre na minha vida fui lá em
fortaleza e foi [ __ ] pra cá e agora vai
ser melhor ele vai ser um lugar maior
que vai caber mais gente vai fazendo
sucesso é muito bom você de fortaleza
que é que meu show é só você ir às lojas
norte e oeste lá no shopping benfica ou
no shopping del paseo waddle passo eu
não sei tem graça e compra fortaleza dia
28 às cinco horas da tarde no centro de
eventos do sebrae ea noite toda vez que
eu viajo volta ou se é boa como fones
ímpar para escutar música eu tenho
contato vocês têm um grande problema com
música que eu só quero te pessoa que eu
não consigo decorar a letra de música
nenhum elemento de verdade num encontrar
eu voltei no lugar
além de errar música que eu tô escutando
eu tenho um grande problema que é
enquanto eu escuto música eu quero
conversar com quem está pertinho só que
música pra mim só presta se for um fone
de s
e foi no máximo em casa ei pegar minha
bolsa pra botar aqui em cima do negócio
avião só pra você sentar eq nao ta e
clamar por que tanta escuta a música tá
escutando tap e fiável com dor não
abaixo o que o povo está a escutar essa
música está escutando não que
completamente de palmas é doida é
testada é muito fácil baixar o volume
está em forma de pães o meu irmão sempre
pra falar qualquer coisa eu cheguei
minha mãe não era pior quando tá
escutando música no máximo eu sei que
vocês têm aquela coisa que você tá assim
sempre uma coisa estranha você fala bem
baixinho sendo agora quanto tá com fone
de ouvido muito pensar alto desse jeito
jabu a mulher gorda da folga tratou
escutando a música se eu fiquei
assim o que é que esse povo tem que essa
música de hoje em dia tem uma coisa
dessa nova na copa encerro empinou o
bumbum para mamá eu só consigo pensar
uma coisa meu deus do céu se a pessoa
está no top 100 é limpinho bumbum com
certeza ela está andando com cara que
não é um bom ela não deixa de se empinar
o bumbum um cara pega um pneu da moto
ela cai lasko no chão quebra costela
quebra bacia vem o samu leva namora a
caminho do hospital a [ __ ] gente é
bom final bumbum encaminhando veja lá
não posso sempre é uma moto sem
segurança pequenas são coisas que eu
acho estranho e não essa música nova em
música antiga também que cada casa é ela
que faz sim eu ando na rua eu toco
cheque e eu mudo uma planta de lugar ela
muda as plantas de lugar
o menino que radical viu e que as
pessoas que já são fãs de mais de música
que passou foi jorge matheus matheus que
jorge mateus pra quem não sabe são duas
pessoas que é normal isso aí adeus
itaqui por jorge mateus está no
supermercado 2012 foi cara é meu irmão
o jorge mateus ele na fila é normal que
a gente visse não estava na fila do
supermercado viu sandy
você pega célula-tronco chega né meu
deus sandy junior tirar foto comigo onde
os mateus eu eu percebi que jorge mateus
é você não precisa escutar jorge mateus
que você pode ser o seu próprio jorge
mateus imagina ser o seu próprio jorge
uma ou joão mateus no caso no banheiro
na sala na cozinha onde você quiser você
jorge mateus com seus amigos é muito
fácil quando você tem que fazer pra
vocês e jorge mateus e colocar num antes
de cada frase um boom o vovô pra onde
foi o z flor rosberg já a moçambique mas
nem jorge mateus em comprar pão é meu pc
do b que é que você quer um bom estava
encostado mais fácil ainda deve ser no
começo você coloca no final da frase não
devesse colocar assim você coloca
cabrinha menos um desde o início você
esteve tão presente tiê e pode ser
qualquer pode ser ruim da água ou na
cruz foi na true
mora ninguém eu vi e tratei de negócio e
aumentar a voz no finalzinho a fazer
pode ter meus pecados caminhados em
jesus isso é gustavo lima
luan santana é muito fácil é como se
fosse jorge mateus
junto com o cabo lima só que com a voz
um pouco mais ruim e não quer dizer que
seja muito longe de mim gosto muito
lança tam e gol só tem uma coisa e não
consegue cantar senão apontar para
pessoa
louçã se amarrar no brasil e assim você
pega jorge mateus gusttavo lima junto em
um só deixa a bola mais foi um pouquinho
aponta a pessoa faça nenhum erro está
nem quem esteja belinha aguardar um lago
mês rumaram nela vem uma lua e tapam
nela uma mensagem não precisa atacar o
lado prata junto nossos carros sem o
pregão com 19 horas tomava no verão não
tem bumbum loudon
nunca é bom sim adora
eu também acho que é muito fácil lucas
nunca nunca mozão que dirá a moça ou
moço não é muito fácil nunca joguei em
um negócio que ele como se ele tivesse
percebido a qualquer momento o rei dele
como se tivessem percebido quando ele
fala parece ele fala para enfrentar tem
um orgasmo eu pensei só estou muito
feliz de estar aqui no canal universal
nunes em princesa ou me deseja boa sorte
e hernanes que só especial o que vou
encontrar alguém um time quer a coisa e
tal
você me esperava nem fazer é seu
príncipe cheio de dependendo os
infelizmente sou um só um cara normal e
bem extensa voltam bem doente eu to com
febre
eu estou com febre alta com dor e
arranca então isso jorge mateus gusttavo
lima lança também lucas lúgubre pai eu
espero que você tenha se divertido que
ninguém tenha seu pedido à obsessão
brincadeira para todos vocês dia 28 no
centro de eventos do sebrae em fortaleza
há cinco horas da tarde ingresso
a loja norte e oeste shopping benfica e
del paseo onde eu passo eu não sei se
você tiver gostar você tivesse
identificado é só você deixar um gostei
aqui no youtube se você tiver um
facebook você clique em curtir é
interessante que você marca que tem
alguém foi de jorge mateus jable mullan
santana lucas do maqueiro sair os
comentários que ele vê a brincadeira se
quiser mandar esse vídeo por lucas logo
pode mandar quer mandar pro santana
morte do gustavo semana para jorge
mateus mandei pra todo mundo assistir
muito obrigado mesmo e se inscreve no
canal para nunca perder nenhum minuto tá
no twitter aí tem que ser a ajuda de
mais um óbito não tá muito obrigado a
assistir o vídeo até aqui suavização foi
muito importante pra mim e gostam de
você pensa